we have to exactly I mean reputation is
proven then eight on the shot clock tied
up there by Harris elevates and hence
Booker fading through his left fires for
three knocks it down
hey I mean you think about the end one
opportunities the continuation
opportunity from 15-20 years ago you've
got guys like Stefan Booker Big Five
sound is gonna be which team doesn't
overly rely on their three-point shot
Booker runs out off of the turnover and
gets the easy Jam Murray matched up
defensively on Booker battle of the 1a
Wildcats and number one wedding that
battle there his Booker hadrianic to
move book blue to fall who to book those
sons number one jerseys popping up Oh
wide open look Oh mom and you know what
he'll do with that cashing it in from
deep yeah Ulis is scoreless so far
tonight
Booker's elevating hitting and giving
the and-one opportunity seven points
Murray inside but ties a chamber the
former 250 layer of the year says no no
not on my watch butcher gets inside
left-hand finish and the foul this is
defender chance to pick it off
Booker inside left-hand money making it
easy
sounds a done a good job of repelling
the Nuggets e3 on the way the Booker and
down its nose a Greek POW to fling it
Booker with the crossover gets its sign
right hand finish